es el desgarrador llanto de la migración
este viernes en chile las autoridades
expulsaron a decenas de personas a
bolivia un drama para miles de
venezolanos como isabel camargo lo
dijeron que no que no podían no pasar
no tenían los pasos nosotros los
venezolanos
estilo tropical o tierra de ellos de
comer chilena nos respondía lo que podía
pasar lo trataron mal pues ahí desde el
miércoles la frontera chilena está en
estado de emergencia este control
militar no está gustando a los vecinos
de la zona puesto que no pueden
abastecerse de alimentos y productos
básicos que normalmente obtienen de
bolivia lamentablemente producto del
decreto de estado de excepción en
nuestra comuna se está produciendo un
desabastecimiento en la comuna en
general debido a que los pobladores de
colchones no tienen posibilidad de
acceder a productos de primera necesidad
precisamente en colchones hay un
improvisado campamento para los
migrantes que logran cruzar desde
bolivia donde están hacinadas entre 200
y 400 personas a 3700 metros del nivel
del mar enfrentándose al inclemente
altiplano se encuentran con el rechazo
de autoridades y parte de la población
chilena
yo sé que gente de mi país que ha hecho
daño aquí ya lo mejor en otras partes
pero no todos somos
gente muy buena desde comienzos de 2022
se han registrado tres mil ingresos
irregulares a chile en 2021 fueron más
de 23.000 chile tiene cerca de 15
millones de emigrantes y según la
organización internacional para las
migraciones es el tercer país con más
migrantes de américa latina después de
argentina y colombia